hi everybody thanks for
joining me today uh and also uh a big
thanks to
labyrinths for organizing this virtual
conference
uh my name is ben borgo i am the
portfolio manager for the genome
engineering modulation group at
milliport sigma
which is the life science business of
merck kgaa darkstat germany
today i'm going to tell you about some
of the work that we've done
in developing immuno oncology cell line
standards and how these standards can
be used to improve potency testing in
various immunotherapy therapies for
various immunotherapies
so within millipore sigma we have a
number of groups which
are dedicated to the development of
genome engineering tools
and we also have several groups that
focus on using those genome engineering
tools to create
novel cell lines cell models
and other engineered cells for
for various purposes one of these groups
cell design studio specifically
focuses on the types of cell models that
are relevant for immuno oncology
research
and most work that i'll talk about today
was done either
with materials produced by cell design
studio or actually by our scientists
within
cell design studio
so as i mentioned we develop and use a
wide variety of gene editing tools
these tools include but are not limited
to crispr based tools
things like nucleuses as well as crispr
activation and
interference uh in crispr integration
using
uh homologous recombination or hdr
focused tools
it also includes a proprietary
nucleus-based editing tool that we use
called zinc finger nucleuses which are a
little bit older than crispr
technologies
but we use that primarily to generate
models and cell lines that have pure i.t
restrictions than something like crispr
works essentially the same way the same
sorts of applications are accessible
using finger technologies
but in many cases it's much harder to
design and so the expertise that we've
built up with that allows us to do that
effectively so in general we introduced
these tools
uh into cells in a variety of formats
including
things like lentivirus direct
introduction of rnp's into cells
using things like nuclear infection or
electroporation
as well as chemical delivery methods and
we do both
internal and customer research projects
in immuno
oncology cell therapy ips cells and gene
therapies
as a service we offer a wide range of
fully customized project
options depending on our clients needs
our focus
largely being on being a collaborative
research contractor
and so we pride ourselves on being able
to take on
the most difficult or complex projects
and work directly with
our clients in order to solve those
problems when many other
cros might not be able to do such a
thing
so many of the projects that we take on
have common themes
um we often focus on the earlier stages
of research but we can provide gmp-like
process control all the way out in the
early clinical development
our projects range from gene modulation
and knockouts to difficult integration
and generation of reporter constructs
really there's no project too difficult
there's no project too large we'd like
to again take on the things
that we find most challenging and some
of the projects that i'll tell you about
today
um fall into those categories
so we take on these projects and try to
deliver exceptional results
using a number of key contributions
uh first we develop and utilize our own
unique and proprietary gene editing
reagents so
this can be things like crispr where we
have an extensive ip portfolio or they
can be things like a measurement pool
with the sync fingers
many of these become available through
our cell design studio
well before they can be purchased by
external researchers meaning
we provide immediate access to the most
state-of-the-art tools
via our service offering our cell line
engineering services make these tools
accessible by helping you design your
research projects and choose the right
tools for the right job
and as i mentioned we provide full
service cell line development across the
entire development pipeline
the next thing i want to talk about is a
couple of cell lines that we have
developed
how those are being used to make
immunotherapy development assessment
more standardized
and more consistent the first project i
want to discuss
is the development of our what we call
our landing pad cell lines
and so as most of you probably know
selection of model systems
for studying for example tcr's is often
a trade-off between the robustness of
the system
and the relevance of the biology so for
example primary t
cells can be very difficult culture but
are the actual cells
that are representative of biology when
you're looking at
immunotherapies or how a patient's
immune system reacts
to something like a cancer treatment um
and sure cat cells on the other hand can
be grown pretty easily
but they're not the perfect proxy for
primary t cells being an immortalized
version their underlying biology
has been altered and often the tcrs that
they present are not
fully representative of what you would
see in a normal biological specimen
so what if you could then engineer those
geocats to express the specific tcr of
interest rather than
the melange of tcrs that you might get
in a
standard jerk outline this is the
question that we asked ourselves as we
decided to engineer some of these
landing pad lines and so the basic
concept with
landing pad cell lines is that we
provide a readily interchangeable set of
cassettes
that are integer integrated into a
variety of biologically
relevant cell lines and so one of those
is jerk hats like i mentioned
and then the others a five four nines
eight three seven fives
uh hct-116s and as uh on a custom basis
thp1 cells
um are also biologically relevant cell
lines for different cancer types and
are good cell models for a number of
oncology
studies and so the landing pad insert
i'm showing here at the bottom of the
slide
where there are several cassettes that
are interchangeable using pre-mediated
recombination
which is much more straightforward to
use than some of the existing
technologies for doing homologous
recombination
at various genome sites the cassette is
integrated into the aavs1 safe harbor
locus
which allows the integration of
individual gene constructs with limited
disruption of
other target genes in the cell this
simplifies the process
especially for situations where you want
to express a single gene construct
like tcr's in this case in one of these
listed cell lines and it makes it so
they don't have to worry about off
target effects
or integration of your construct into
sites other than this specific one
and a good example of how we use these
is the application i mentioned
which is the introduction of over
expression of a single uniform tcr of
interest
we've used these landing pad cell lines
to generate
tcr expressing your cats where we're
able to quickly substitute in
any tcr of interest using cremated
pre-mediated exchange
and then we can screen for very we can
screen these cells that are expressing
the tcr's
for t cell activation against hla
presented antigens
so this just one example one simple
example
of where we can in a uniform and
controlled way
introduce specific tcrs into a known
population of cells
and then either screen those cells or
assay those cells
knowing what's on the surface rather
than kind of working the other way
around and doing the assay and trying to
figure out what was on the surface of
the things that we
were looking at and so uh
in that vein but shifting here slightly
um antigen presenting cells
also provide the same sort of a
challenge for consistency of expression
of their their presented antigens and so
we've similarly similarly engineered
several panels of antigen presenting
cells
which provide for controlled levels of
antigen expression
so these cells are engineered again
within biologically relevant cell lines
you can see them listed here on the
right raw g cells uh 8549s and a375s
this is a distinct advantage over any
sort of bead-based or
artificial support of antigens that are
used to
activate t cells but they do offer
a similar advantage of having controlled
levels of antigen expression
that take that make them much more
versatile for determining things like
potency curves or other metrics that
require
precise enumeration uh of the antigen
uh things like t cell activation or
cytokine release thresholds
uh and so these sort of controlled
systems that again
are still representative of the biology
that we're trying to study
um provide a much better system to
understand what's going on uh in these
cell lines
so i mentioned uh hla presented antigens
when i was discussing our
landing pad lines we also have developed
a full panel of
monoallelic hla cell lines each of which
has had
all of its endogenous b2ms knocked out
in the expression of a single hla
subtype introduced via lentiviral
expression
so these lines that we have listed here
represent over 60 percent of the hla
types in the general population
and they do again provide a controlled
system for
testing antigen presentation in the
associated t
cell activation so now that i've showed
you some of these tools that we want to
utilize
uh and that we have created so that we
can improve testing
i want to go through one application
that we worked on with the collaborator
as part of an early collaboration using
specifically
these hla cell lines and so the basic
idea here
is that our client had a suite of
antigenic peptides
that are known to be presented in the
hla complex
they also knew that patients with a
specific hla subtype
generate t cells which actively attack
cells presenting those antigenic
peptides
and they would like to understand if the
t cells generated in these patients with
again with a specific hla subtype
also attack the antigen when it's
presented in other hla subtypes
so they sought to understand if t cells
activated by that peptide library
would be subtype specific so to answer
these questions they required two things
the first is hla type t cells
or pvmcs from donors that were
stimulated with the peptide libraries
that's something that our client
generated
and the second thing that they required
was those monoallelic hla cells
that would allow them to test the
efficiency in a controlled system
with which t cells can kill hla subtype
specific
tumor cells and so this is the primary
component that we provided within this
collaboration so to set up this
experiment we first verified that the
controls
behave as expected specifically in the
first figure you can see that the
knockout hla
is shown in red as the baseline for no
hla expression
this is stained using hla antibodies and
sorted by fax
in blue the shift of the peak represents
the presence of a fluorescent
anti-hla binding to our engineered
hla subtype cells subtyped cells
in the second figure we introduced the
expression of the peptide antigens
and showed that in in show the same
shift um demonstrating that the hla is
still present
and it's active with the addition of the
peptide antigen expression
in the final figure we have expressed
the peptide antigen in the absence of
hla
[Music]
and so the library is present but the
hla is not and as expected we don't see
surface presentation of the hla when we
stain with that anti-hla antibody
so this basically tells us that those
cell lines that we've we've engineered
behave as expected they're able to
present
the hla complexes and the antigen within
the hla
when the hla complex is knocked out and
that is part of our hla panels the
knockout cell lines
those antigens cannot be presented on
the surface
and so to test the killing efficiency of
t
cells first tbmcs are extracted from hla
type donors
that sample is stimulated with the
antigenic peptide library that i
mentioned before
activated t-cells are generated that
should recognize the hla presented
antigens
in a cell-based assay each of each set
of the donor t cells
is then introduced to our cell panel and
all of the controls
and the killing of the panel of the
cells in the panel is measured both by
cytotoxicity and
interferon gamma production both are
are measured by staining and sorting by
facts
and both are proxies for the killing
activity
of the cells recognizing the antigen on
the surface
if the t cells are hla subtype specific
we would expect that they would
only kill the cell lines in the panel
that match the donor of the t
cells but would not interact with the
others they would not be able to
recognize the
the antigen on the surface of the other
hla subtypes
so that's the basic setup we did this
with a number of different hla
subtypes and a number of different hla
types donors so the hla panel that we've
generated covers most of the donor
subtypes that
this particular client was interested in
which isn't surprising given that our
panels cover 60 plus percent of the
population
um it didn't cover all of the target
alleles
uh so there were they had some donor uh
pvmcs that had hla subtypes that sat
outside of what we had in our panel
this is something that we could have
always engineered as an additional cell
line
however this particular client felt that
the representation we got across their
hla's of interest was sufficient for
this particular study um
and so here are the results from the
cytotoxicity interferon gamma assays
performed
at our collaborator so the red bars
represent significant killing of t
cells as measured by cytolysis and
interferon gamma production
only one of the donors specifically
donor two in the second column
had significant killing in an off target
subtype
and that is represented there by the red
bars
so the the bigger the red bar the more
the killing activity
of that specific type and you can see in
most cases
the killing activity of a donor's
specific pbmcs
is isolated to a single hla subtype so
uh t cells generated from a donor with a
known hla type
seem to be specific for killing cells
the same hla subtype
with this particular set of antigens um
this indicates that something like a
cell-based therapeutic targeting these
peptides
as an estrogen would only be efficient
if the target cells were of the same
type
um it would have to be specific for the
hla subtypes there's
uh one unique example specifically with
donor number two where there's some
cross-reactivity
uh between um between different subtypes
but
we didn't explore this any further at
this point
it seems pretty clear that the trend is
uh in general
uh that to that specificity um
so this level of detail wouldn't be
obtainable without those monoallelic hla
target cells
and so having that those those
engineered cells really enabled
a controlled study of how pbmcs
specifically reacted with this antigen
peptide library
and how specific
donor t cells are for these different
antigens
so in conclusion the primary t cells
stimulated with an antigenic peptide
library were utilized alongside a suite
of monoallylic
hla cells to enumerate the specificity
of the t cell response
uh single change hla b2m constructs
within these cell lines
are functional they can present peptides
to the t
cells and the antigen presentation
carries over to a wide range
of hla subtypes the monoallelic lines
thus provide a clean defined background
for assessing this type of cell t-cell
activity
and again this extends not just to the
a549 cells that we tested here
but to the jarcats and the a375s which
make up the other hla panels that we
currently have available
and i would also again mention that if
the particular cell lines
that you are interested in are not a
member of our hla panels we have a
a very robust pipeline for building
these types of
cell panels and so looking at other cell
types is not beyond
the realm of what we would normally do
as part of a collaboration
so i just want to close uh by mentioning
again that millipore sigma
and merck kgaa darmstadt germany provide
a broad range
of development manufacturing services
for cell and gene therapies
this includes the cell design studio
which is the primary focus of what i
talked about today
all of the materials and projects that i
mentioned
were either hatched within cell design
studio
or hatched as part of a collaboration or
project with an outside
with a third party but involving the
work cell design studio
we also offer bioassay validation
services
uh in full service cbmo manufacturing
for things like
cell and gene therapies via our bio
reliance services
and we do cartoon manufacturing and
testing
and so as a company we offer an
extremely close level of collaboration
and partnership
this is something that you might find
lacking in other cbmo's
the projects that i i showed here are
really good examples of how closely we
work
with our partners so please do reach out
to us if you have any projects
on which you believe we can help
questions about the work that we've done
here
or what our capabilities entail
otherwise
the contact information for any of the
materials or service
materials or services i mentioned today
are listed here
and i'm happy to take any additional
questions please do visit our website
some of the other projects that are
related
to this are listed there we have a site
specifically for immuno oncology
these cell line panels are mentioned
there as well as some of the other work
that we've done
with genome engineering tools uh in with
cell
engineering projects so with that i will
close
say thank you for your attention and i
am happy to take any questions that you
have